everything alive right or wrong it's
exactly right everybody you know
everybody good said some people keep
keep their head to their [ __ ]
nineties others loser when they're
[ __ ] twenty and they live a different
type of lifestyle it's [ __ ] up yeah
we're all there's a [ __ ] it's Monday
morning November 19 [ __ ]
greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by my bookie
listen it's Thanksgiving week and you're
still sitting there with [ __ ] with
[ __ ] lint in your pockets you would
you miserable [ __ ] the Thanksgiving is
finally possible for you to get a
hundred percent refund on your bet if
you lose it with the turkey day free
play you can bet the spread on these are
the Bears or the Lions if it wins you
wins if it loses my bookie will give you
money back up to $250 you literally
cannot lose it's no risk or gravy
nothing but [ __ ]
my bookie offers this great product and
they literally never have been better
time to try them out unless the sports
book is offering something like this I
think you should match the switch make
the switch I'm sorry I never heard of a
sports book doing a freebie like this
and I doubt it'll ever happen again
these guys are trustworthy they're fast
they're helpful so I know they're good
for
tell you what logging on to my bookie
right now use promo code Church and get
50 percent deposit bonus that's promo
code Church you don't need a promo code
for the free for the turkey free play if
you lose will credit the money back into
your account automatically so what the
hell are you waiting for
listen this only happens at my bookie
and this only happens because you got an
uncle Joey number two I don't know if
you know this it's Black Friday that
means somebody's gonna kick what's the
name Kevin Megan in the stomach who's
the chick that did blackface Oh Megan
Kelly making Kelly's gonna get kicked in
the stomach I'm Black Friday some black
bags on the show up on a big black dick
and jerk off on a little face he's gonna
be petrified it's gonna be gel like
Jamie Lee
[ __ ] my Halloween every shoot alone
the chicks face and they look at y'all
weird I feel like do they wanna talk to
you for an hour like something bad
happen it's Black Friday [ __ ] it's that
time of year again on it Black Friday
say Thanksgiving night the 22nd and it
makes the sale of the year and they'll
deliver with the deepest discounts of
all you you ready for this
25% on supplements 18% on fitness
including Star Wars and Marvel and
certifications 20% on foods 50% off DVDs
and books and 30% off apparel in
addition to that they're gonna have
massive price cuts you'll put up on it
calm Black Friday slash Church and get
your party started and that even
includes out for brain so [ __ ] you
can start the year off with a new frame
of mind you know I'm saying you didn't
want to finger banging but now on it
made you [ __ ] come to your senses and
your finger banging [ __ ] did you get
chlamydia on your finger who gives a
[ __ ] jack kick that melee it's Monday
the point 9 and 19th of November Monday
morning my main man said hey from
[ __ ] uh what something like 22 band's
ministry ministry being the main one
three-headed snake
three headed snake and it's compadre
Caesar Caesar where he sets out we're
here on a Monday also also from ministry
Anthony headed snake how long have you
been with ministry uh 40 going on going
up four years in February but we've
known each other almost 20 years almost
20 years yeah from the neighborhood no
we were in we met on tour when I was in
society one and you were in I was an
event called pisses me raisers yeah it's
from Texas from El Paso so I've known
this stage for yeah we met like on tour
when we were touring in like [ __ ]
station wagons and [ __ ] and like
literally like doing the country like
that and I thought we were in luxury and
we're in the shitty Oh
Winnipeg RV yeah
remember when you were you at that level
then that's it
you were ready for what Zeppelin Led
Zeppelin move over
yeah we're showing up in a [ __ ] 83
Winnebago and a Winnebago with a [ __ ]
replacement flat tire yeah that's just
getting you there I know that you don't
know what's gonna act a man using this
you know if I'm into a room full of
[ __ ] to have an apartment for a
week you don't know you really don't
know what was a gamble what a gamble to
put like it your wife into like
especially back then man you know you
know this when when you tour when you
first start touring you end up crashing
in people's places and on the floor and
[ __ ] in bathtubs like people you do a
gig you rarely make any money back then
it's just enough to get you to the next
town like you barely make gas money to
get to the next town and you end up
meeting people and then they're like hey
you know if you guys want to crash at my
place you know it's crazy isn't that
great and it's like if people are doing
blow and like people it's like kinds of
insanity going around you staying in the
same city more than one night or is it
all one-nighters it depends sometimes
like on this - we got coming up we're
doing a couple of same city two nights
but it varies sometimes we do often
times it's one city one night and then
after the gig crew packs up and then you
drive all night and then wake up in the
next in the next town yeah and then back
then I mean dude no [ __ ] crew like
you're you're you're setting up your own
[ __ ] you're selling your own merch
you're driving yourself like taking like
turns you know what I mean like driving
all night
we have shifts and [ __ ] [ __ ] up
tonight yeah whoo stayin sober and yet
to drive yeah it was [ __ ] crazy but I
mean were taking a gig I was living in
Seattle I was just starting to cook I
was doing comedy for years I took a gig
in Alaska and asked and you know it was
just a [ __ ] bar nice you know it was
just a stage with a bar and it's what's
the ratio in Alaska men the women are
like yeah it's been crazy this is
the six there was like three [ __ ]
women for every 20 mm so I guess
something happened the whole town
thrived or fishing mm-hmm so when the
boats came in the hottest strip club in
the nation was that strip club sure the
hottest [ __ ] from no way a really
high up to Alaska took for two weeks to
take those [ __ ] fisherman's money and
show I don't know so we were there
during that like when the fishermen were
and yeah was spending but I'll never
forget like I was going to Alaska I
[ __ ] my career's on the way up you
know and we get there and the condo was
a room that had been [ __ ] in and
sucked when they had used it for pornos
people got shot he asked people got put
in there that was dead for three days
and they had a broken window had a
broken window someone flew out of
probably know like a piece of window was
broken I was a dancer we'd like you know
so the whole night you froze to death
you had ten blanket on a hooded
sweatshirt and they even had a heater in
the room it didn't matter
yeah [ __ ] Alaska no it was dark all
day like it was that time of the day we
know hey I'm it Wow
I still remember those gazing whenever I
go to do something now I go wow look
it's a theater yeah I think of one of
those now automatically one pops up that
goes ah yeah I paid my sins for this
show yeah the reason why there's Lebanon
your people here is because I had paid
your dues left in a room yeah with no
[ __ ] window you know yeah I remember
we're walking around in or was it man
outside of Boston or what so it's that
the place that we was her
yeah and Worcester and me and Cyn or
walking around we saw we had a day off
there that day be before our show and it
was all these vans outside of the venue
and all these dudes hanging out in vans
and sleep in advance and we're walking
by and where we were talking about those
days and we're like you remember those
days men and
good days you know times you're
remembering you're like you know you
pain you yeah you have to go through all
that [ __ ] to to be able to to do stuff
at you know level now next level stuff
and but I mean you know I often remember
his hands or next level stuff
Alessi go left unless you roll through
that oh yeah very much so
dude I remember I remember being in a
van and and like touring in a van
and I was comfortable hints in this in
the space in be on the floor in between
both benches that was like my space and
I was like I picked that space because
it was like the warmest space on the
floor in the winter and I was good with
it like I was like that's cool that's
like my bunk right there yeah you know
with like six other dudes but that
that's that's the way it was back then
was you one try that once you have that
certain belief that something could
happen your life becomes unstoppable
like it's like mm-hmm everything in your
life stops politics sports you know the
all that matters is your mom your dad
what your brother's doing and whatever
heart you picked yeah and you sometimes
you really ignore your house oh yeah you
know you ignore your health you drink
too much you do blow you eat fried fried
foods you ignore so much of so many
aspects of your life because of you fall
in love mm-hmm so deeply with this
belief that this could possibly happened
that's true
and then every six months you climb a
new ladder your agent calls and says hey
you're not doing a [ __ ] hole Gowalla
Nebraska this week we made a detour
you're opening up for such-and-such in
Denver a band fell out you know and then
you meet them and then they call you six
months later and say hey you want to do
a tour with us next you know you're on
the tour with Alison change right and
even though you're the first band that
throwing cans at yeah doesn't matter but
yeah it doesn't matter and you walk off
that stage you know like I want some
change is gonna come in three bands
behind this you know and next thing you
know now you
and guy on the bill mm-hmm and you're
doing that for two years but you come
out with an album and the album does
well and you know it's just such a climb
but then the drummer wants to bring his
Chinese girlfriend into the family Yoko
over so now you gotta get rid of him now
you gotta start the whole who [ __ ] Ben
shit's exactly he's going yeah you keep
going and then for six months something
happens the house you pay for a night
you can't pay the mortgage so now you
got to go back into the studio and play
the guitar and may believe you want to
hear this idiot sing yeah why you yeah
that sounds great
I want a more Spanish sound from your
sin and you're there you want Santana
you wants it right you want Carlos go
Carlos do you want to pawn me I'm said
Santana you know since Anna you know I'm
saying but it's amazing what the life is
and also you got a call from the dude he
put an album on it's number one and
you're the guitar player on the tour and
here you are back again now you put
together three headed snake and their
[ __ ] rocket and now you know it's
it's such a [ __ ] dog eat dog and one
day you sit there you know I've been
doing this for 27 years
these [ __ ] vets go over there for six
months if they got PTSD I got something
PTSD STDs I got something I got
something because I've been beat up yeah
I beat up emotionally and even when you
get to where you're going there's more
drama now yeah now you got sixteen
lawyers exactly now you got 16 lawyers
by the way you gotta change the lyric in
that song because Kmart will get mad
they won't put that out and now you're
like what the [ __ ] what my opponents got
a Kmart shop right White Castle what am
I gonna use it's it never ends people
think like Bruce Springsteen I guarantee
has a problem with Sherm you know
they've shown three movies about music
in the last couple of years and each
movie had a cop conflict they wanted to
do something the record label did not
and they beat him Ray Charles wanted to
do an album the record label said no
Johnny
- wanted to do live from Folsom Folsom
the record label said no and Queen
wanted to do Bohemian Rhapsody and the
people were like we don't we don't we
don't get it
no okay [ __ ] no yeah and they they went
and did it
it takes all those steps and to be just
I'm thankful every day that I'm
strolling comedy the other night
somebody sat next to me Adam the talent
coordinator at The Comedy Store in
Saturday night and he said something
like oh you know bro to be 55 and still
be coming down here and doing spots like
that's [ __ ] great
[ __ ] yeah most guys are 55 are on a
cruise ship
tap dancing and [ __ ] singing songs are
you [ __ ] kidding me it's true man had
a Monday morning at 9:00 a.m. stoned to
the gills
cuz the baby came to bed last night at
9:30 I got a stomach ache and she was
working she worked the attorney though
she worked me first
yeah I told that with Bob attorneys yeah
you gotta have a juba from time to time
you lower your standards you gotta start
low so now she comes to me with a
bellyache I got a child with mother the
mothers telling her now yeah so he's got
him down from the [ __ ] turtle [ __ ]
study singing songs at 5:30 in the
morning there's a turtle she's got it
says singing some [ __ ] songs I'm
having nightmares about [ __ ] I'm in
Thailand in a cave with 12 kids I'm
hearing this turtle thank God I had a
Pete this time as well stay up I had
some coffee Hector did a couple bonnets
so she has you asked the mom for her oh
yes he comes to me with the stomach
aching [ __ ] and then she gets in bed and
she's jumping up and down in the mines
like I thought you had a stomach ache I
do i always take blue I always take
JetBlue yeah and they give you a little
package to go and mint and one of the
things in the package this is those
things that you put on sigh and I think
they asked her she took a lot she sleeps
oh she does
so every night she has those [ __ ] Zsa
Zsa Gabor things on I'm over in the
middle nice little sleeping next to
hamburgers
wake up [ __ ] days on I'm like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with my life I gotta
get together oh man everything you said
though is true about the steps and you
know it for the past well [ __ ] I started
doing this professionally if you want to
call it that at about 18 19 and it was
always just [ __ ] blinders for me like
I died you're exactly right in that you
forget other things you don't even think
about other things because you just
focused on what you love to do and what
your your dream is and you know
relationships [ __ ] fall apart
everything just [ __ ] be sorted I yeah
I mean and you miss a lot of [ __ ] dude
it's impossible for us to like make
plans because you know you think you
so-and-so my cousin's getting married or
so-and-so's birthday or whatever and
they you know everyone makes all these
plans to do [ __ ] like that we can never
we never know where the hell we're gonna
be at and for us to get from point A to
point B we know that we've got to do
this no matter what no matter what is
happening over here and it's it's a
tough thing not everyone understands
that [ __ ] and not everyone will make
that sacrifice you know very [ __ ]
excuse you know [ __ ] yeah you have to do
what they so absolutely I'm already
[ __ ] up we have no wedding rehearsal
when's that Sunday night at 8:00 I'll be
in a plan you're done you're in no
danger I think it change the date time
exactly and I change the date this and
actually got sick I don't know what
happens to guys like hysterical like how
many [ __ ] things people send now and
you really really really feel bad
because we travel for a living
hmm so once we get off the road like
we're like I don't want to see LAX you
know for six weeks yeah I love that
feeling of saying I don't see how I
asked for six weeks
okay I'm apt to see Burbank twice yeah
maybe I gig in San Jose sure and maybe
you do one in Portland but there's
something about not going Alex the song
about it and then somebody hits you in
an invite and you look at the invite and
then your heart you go you know what I'm
gonna change who I am I'm gonna go to
this family [ __ ] thing and you look
at it hard and hard and also you look at
the airlines and it's a little pricey
you know it's not it's out of the range
if it was more than two dollars it's
pricey like dad looks more than two
hours but then the price jumped Fogg I
thought this would be like 350 and it's
400 yeah then you look you some getting
a cab it's not going to the hotel
getting dressed to go to a [ __ ]
family thing when you don't talk and
then answer questions why don't you
marry your grandmother's leg hurts then
you got to get back on the elevator and
get on a plane and go what the [ __ ] was
that I need rest more than ever you're
gonna say I got a text week tour I get
right [ __ ] people really don't seem to
understand that they really don't mm-hmm
get all understand the touring part
three nights in a row you're not 20 no
more mm-hmm you need your sleep this
[ __ ] out jorgensen he's out of his
mind
12-hour rehearsals the other day you
like good we would have taken him one
and [ __ ] yeah but that's that's part of
the process and you don't want to be at
that level is what it takes I love these
people yeah yeah where's four hours now
and now I can really you know
everything's so meticulously and make
sure the photographers there
everything's so meticulous you want to
make sure that I mean essentially you
want to give people the show that they
paid for really you know I mean it's
like sonically everything has to be
there that I rehearsals are long but
they're long for a reason and it's it's
to get everything perfect precision is
like you know that's Alice thing is
precision you know make sure everything
is just play your [ __ ] parts [ __ ] we
used to we used to rehearse a whole
[ __ ] month before the old tours when
he was still in El Paso and out there he
had his own studio and [ __ ] like that
the whole entire month we would rehearse
before a tour and most bands rehearse a
week two weeks or something like that so
he's always been very very on top of the
band sounding [ __ ] rock solid a
hundred percent like you know everything
has to be perfect and that doesn't
happen with just a couple days and and
just you know I that's fine that's
that's good enough no it's got to be
[ __ ] perfect consistent every night
and you know it seems a bit excessive to
other bands but this band has a lot of
[ __ ] going on on stage there's a lot of
moving parts that you know have to be on
[ __ ] you know a hundred percent so
it's just why we work so much it's not
your traditional you know drums guitar
bass vocal band there's a lot of [ __ ]
yeah everything from the visuals I mean
everything everything that we do on
stage is just it's mapped out planned
out in sync with everything with the
music the visuals are in sync with the
music the vocals the [ __ ] that's going
on behind us everything is in sync so
that means that whole team has to be on
the same page the entire step of the way
so that takes a lot of time you know
it's a lot of rehearsing but you guys
ever have nightmares that someone's
wrong dude I couldn't yeah past two
nights I could not [ __ ] sleep to save
my life past two nights yeah so I guess
10 the last night was like the second
night in a row that I actually [ __ ]
got sleep because I was thinking about
everything
to go through in my head and [ __ ] you
know I mean it's just yeah yeah
sometimes yeah he's getting sleep it
gets a new head I can't imagine first
off when I got into comedy the first ten
years of a seven nights a week you know
it was something that Roth
it was just another [ __ ] day yeah
well I woke up in more than the first
thing I walk about was where was I get
on stage number two is how was I gonna
get 40 hours were half a gram that was
the truth that was my day you start in
New York I started in Denver well and
then I got chased out to Seattle and
then Seattle I can't die why if it was
the same drunk
you know what are you living in Denver
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah and I developed
no path so really that's why I'm from
the comic strip that's where I'm from
the West Side yeah but reads Bart reads
German I came up and I did a lot of work
they have like weird that I'm watching
North Coast now yeah and it's about El
Paso oh yeah it's really good until Paso
now now they [ __ ] El Paso was waiting
for the dude funny I'm tremendous I love
all the echoes [ __ ] but these days I
booked something and I'm not up for it
so [ __ ] ten minutes before the show
wait ten minutes before the show
something happens I put a smile on my
face and like oh you know what I'm ready
for Freddy I'm ready to rock
I can't imagine thirteen people going
through that same thing yeah
you guys do how many shows a week four
or five about four or five yeah we'll
have days off in between some days we'll
have two days off in between but it
depends on distance and if that day off
is gonna be a travel day or an off day
in whatever city were playing in the
next that's usually what it is if we
have if there's a day off it's usually a
travel day if there's two days off it's
definitely travel because we're really
far away from the next destination but
yeah there's some nights or some tours
where you know we do five six in a row
Bravo what about driving to Hungary on
it on the last though oh yeah these were
holy [ __ ] that was how many hours I was
uh 17 hours on the bus 17 or 18 hours on
the bus with with 17 18 people [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] brutal dude we literally pulled
up the crew unloaded everyone was like
super hungry yeah
it was raining you know I was I mean so
no nights man it's literally we pull up
and doors are about to open already and
the crew is just hauling ass to get our
you know was it Bristol yeah we like it
was like 30 minutes before doors and
they still had to set up all our stage
and everything and some of those drives
are just insane now they gotta just end
up in the bus like you know already just
it's [ __ ] go and start crazy in there
and then you got to be on to get up on
stage and [ __ ] you know like
everything has been going great
and you just got a [ __ ] smile on your
face and get your [ __ ] head ready
yeah sure got to go up yeah why do you
think I think is that people always talk
about similarities between musicians and
comedians the only thing the only thing
different that I am thinking about now
is like the show it seems like the
opening band usually gets [ __ ] on like
opening people go for the opening
comedians and something they laugh every
time like every time I hear people going
to a concert like oh we can go late so
it was opening we can get like it like
they don't seem to get as much respect
yeah it sucks it seemed it I mean to me
it almost seems like in a weird way it's
sort of like this rite of passage kind
of thing it's just like every like when
you're an opener you just know you're
gonna get [ __ ] on you know that people
are gonna even if you're good like it it
just seems to be it to me almost like
that whole paying your dues thing in a
weird way I don't know why that is but
that's what it's been like when we were
openers I mean I remember it you know I
remember getting [ __ ] on I remember
[ __ ] I remember [ __ ] getting
scissors thrown at dude I was dude I had
[ __ ] sin Philly
I had [ __ ] scissors fly right by my
head when we were the openers I've been
burned with like lit cigarettes and [ __ ]
like yeah it just you know why
who knows it's just but it seems to be
like that with with openers my mom isn't
a long time ago
when I got into music was the late 70s
and the rumor was you had 30 minutes
because the opening band I think I went
to to in choice shows with that attitude
and then Black Sabbath came with Van
Halen hmm and the word already on the
street was to make sure not to miss the
opening better so we went in court
van Halen destroy him murdered weilman's
murder and murdered yeah
Van Halen was that Black Sabbath was
done but after that I made it a point
this is way before comedy was in my
future well I just made it a point to
give the artist a chance Turk in my shop
let me decide this is way before comma
just some type of respect that I had
because I knew I could never do what you
do so hold your [ __ ] mine to go there
throw [ __ ] at you yeah like I have never
thrown anything at a concert I walked
out of concerts well I've never thrown
anything on a concert yeah something
about me and I always respected that I
can't do what they're doing I can't do
what they're [ __ ] doing my mother
used to throw chicken wings at rusty
stuff I left he played left field
whatever for the Mets
she drew so many chicken wings on that
they used to make us sit on the other
side
that's how pissed off she had rusty
Staub would she eat the chicken or veal
it was either drove cold I just [ __ ]
and he missed the [ __ ] foul ball one
time and he [ __ ] she lost the game
rusty Staub she busted you bet the
matches aren't like that
I get that [ __ ] you know but I don't get
I don't know I don't get I don't get
[ __ ] not walking and while somebody's
on stairs
sure what the hell found my store the
other night and I saw one of the
managers a comic as a talent coordinator
in the back with their phones on and I
sat back there
[ __ ] Bruin if you know anything about
me there's a movie I called the family
with De Niro mm-hmm one of the worst
movies ever made Michelle Pfeiffer in a
hot little girl but it's having a
situation in the witness relocation plan
then it flashes back to him what he
would do if this was his old life yeah
and he shows him stabbing people hit
number pipes put them in truck cars
right there I would've stabbed off like
right in their chairs to boot we sat
next to them watch the show and then
gone on stage they'd let this guy in the
heart just sit there and listen solve a
problem in blood on the way the stage I
wipe the knife on your shirt and I walk
out there with the knife and face off
Laurel Canyon let the dogs find the good
luck [ __ ] I'll bury that thing so
[ __ ] deep but it's like I've always
respected the arts I don't know why like
yeah I don't know why you got something
to show me and I go I'm gonna keep my
match I'm not gonna heckle you I'm not
gonna help you I'm not gonna write a bad
review I'm gonna suck it in for a month
and think about what the [ __ ] I just saw
yeah trust me I've seen some bad [ __ ]
now you see some badge yeah that you
sitting there feel bad for the person
look enough psychiatric service like
this is [ __ ] up that this guy invited
us down here
he's thinking he's gonna get away with
this no music how bad of music have you
seen Oh
dude have you sat there
said I don't know whether I should go up
there hit him with the guitar or take
the guitar ain't your [ __ ] at
least get something I'm home MacDonald
had a farm anything is better than what
the [ __ ] they playing up there it's true
yeah I'm seeing a lot of shitty acts and
but you know I I I'm the same way in the
sense that I always give people respect
and I did I never once even in today's
age of like the internet and [ __ ] like
that like I'm not one of those the
[ __ ] go on and talk [ __ ] about this
band because I don't like this guy like
you know I mean like how that happens
nowadays and [ __ ] like that like dude
I've never if I don't like I don't like
them like that's it it ends there like
I'm not gonna am I gonna do you know I
mean let alone you look red yeah let
alone like throw [ __ ] at people or do so
I remember one of the early tours and we
were out with twisted and we were
opening for them the whole [ __ ] floor
would turn around and just have their
middle finger at us just flipping us off
our entire set like imagine walking out
just because you're the opener people
would just turn around and just be
standing like this like wow and you're
playing you're up there doing your thing
and and that's all you're looking at is
how these [ __ ] middle fingers at you
man it's [ __ ] brutal it was early
[ __ ] towards you know I remember the
for the first tour that we did together
which was what almost 20 years ago or
whatever I witnessed like this dudes
band get totally [ __ ] on by one of the
other bands that that we're all touring
with and stuff and that was like on a
nightly basis that almost I was [ __ ]
brutal so we were like the we were it
was a Threepenny Banville we were though
at the time I was in the first band the
opening band and then you guys were
second and then there was a headliner in
the headliner would just complete dicks
to us and just you know every every
chance they could tried to [ __ ] keep
our money tried to just just everything
and we were pretty green back then we
didn't know a lot of [ __ ] and you know
you get taken advantage of and all that
crap but yeah it was [ __ ] those are
crazy days mad rudl as we were traveling
in a [ __ ] vortex
or six guys six guys cross country
across the u.s. several times over in a
Ford Explorer there's six seats in a
Ford Explorer no no you make it work
ya know do the math in my head like did
him place in the back so yeah five seats
and the place in the back way up of
luggage yeah put exactly yeah and [ __ ]
so you're back there crapple dumpkins
yeah you need 15 chiropractors Paul is
it don't give handjobs
just a straight nap the [ __ ] play the
Geordie much around it's it's it's a
[ __ ] nightmare it's piano I lived a
little office in Seattle for 125 a month
just like this lived in this office no
shower
they had a [ __ ] and you know the gym
was like the YMCA two blocks from here
so far one of the shower I would have to
walking in the pretense I was gonna work
out and they had q-tips in those days it
was like a it wasn't know why yeah it
was a little nice that blow-dry hasn't
gel I gonna say I'm saying
the toilet paper was soft their towels
like a [ __ ] so I lived in the office
while I showered and did my stuff at the
gym it made me force work out it made me
at the bag for an hour they may be long
the bike and lift weights and then I was
going in gym but it could be done you
know the sacrifices that you put into it
you don't even feel like sacrifices why
are you doing it mm-hmm like if you look
back mm-hmm they don't feel like
sacrifices mm-hmm it was like you were
doing it the same reason why somebody
would join a militia you know they have
a belief in something they believe that
the u.s. is evil let's start a militia
and you have that belief you you're
blinded by this yeah dumb faith
yeah I've been astonished for the last
year and a half of the question is what
makes you go forward with this career at
the four year mark when there's really
nothing going on mom and you gotta sell
it to your parents you got a song to
yourself you know mm-hmm and you're a
barista mm-hmm you know you're a [ __ ]
barista and you're living off the tips
and you hate your job you hate everybody
or you see yourself is on the stage now
touring and shaking your head and chick
sucking your dick signing abortion
[ __ ] paperwork while she's yeah while
she's crying you got a little boy here's
the waiter got Bob Seger on what's that
song Bob Seger wrote about being on the
road again yeah being lonely yeah yeah
yeah hey you are serving a double double
latte some white guy that wants soy milk
you look at them like you know what if I
have a good time here a little bit about
all I want to do is play beer there's
nothing worse than that feeling of being
in that I'm ready for it yeah and in
your stupid mind you don't even ready to
work you just ready for started mm-hmm
you're ready for stardom you know I'm
saying you get that one check and
there's a sale I'm like Foot Locker and
you get yourself like a rock and roll
shirt and you said follow your mirror
and [ __ ] look at yourself and you're
like I'm gonna make it D gonna and you
know went close to it no give no wait
close to remember I'm not being able to
hold jobs down because I would say oh we
have another couple of shows out of town
we'll [ __ ] I'm gonna have to quit this
job and quit and find another job on
this so can you come back and just doing
[ __ ] like that well you know like here's
800 what why don't we do it yeah I know
we're going like doing this boy toy
that's just really good dude Mexican
dudes and then but really it helped me
out a lot he was a hustler you know
there's some people in the business
school and he would go to different bars
and sell him Tommy nights and some
little game 200 and someone who gave me
50 but he always blow dry his hair ain't
have an entourage eight Mexicans with
them
they all had the same haircut [ __ ]
hilarious even the girls all have the
same haircut and [ __ ] you don't me I did
a thousand of his [ __ ] gigs like he
booked different gigs and different bars
he's still at it I could be looking at
his Facebook page yeah
I've been longing to [ __ ] Wow he don't
give a [ __ ] that's his name little whiny
to him host yeah and they're always
doing some type of event lowriders I
Rises [ __ ] tremendous man how do you
know what my point was I'm so [ __ ]
stoned well you were mentioning like you
met like dreaming of someone's hooking
your dick do you guys remember the first
time like a - oh a girl like talk to uni
actually brought her back to the hotel
like I would imagine that'd be like a
dream you never forget yeah IRA I mean
well I remember the first time and it's
so it doesn't seem like a [ __ ] big
deal now but I remember the first time I
got some some girls like backstage and
got naked in the dressing room and [ __ ]
on the road like it was the first time
we were out of LA and uh it was [ __ ]
busy so stupid now but like so we were
we were I think it was in San Francisco
actually and this is over 20 years ago
and we were standing outside the venue
looking at the poster that was outside
the venue you know our poster and [ __ ]
you know where else green and just
taking pictures of this and these two
chicks are walking on the sidewalk and
they're dressed like really like like in
business kind of you know attire and it
was a blonde chick and like a Hispanic
chick and and they're standing there and
they're looking at the poster as well
and they're like uh is that you guys
like yeah and what kind of music and
we're telling them you know it's like
metal whatever and they're like oh you
know we might come back tonight I'm like
yeah whatever so they split so that
night they end up [ __ ] showing up to
the [ __ ] gig and now they're dressing
like they're [ __ ] you know rock chick
attire and and so after the gig I
remember the drummer and I walked down
there and we were talking to them and we
were like you guys
want to come backstage and they're like
yeah sure so they come backstage and we
had you know [ __ ] their drinks and
and all that [ __ ] and I think my drummer
was like so you know who's gonna get
naked first kind of as a joke but the
[ __ ] blonde chick is like [ __ ] it
I'll do it and she just starts [ __ ]
taking her clothes off and [ __ ] and gets
completely naked and then the other one
does and I remember I had those [ __ ]
disposable cameras at the time remember
those [ __ ] old-school disposable ones
and I remember like I was so [ __ ]
blown away that we had naked chicks in
our dressing room you know out of town
on tour and I was taking pictures and
[ __ ] and there were mirrors like all the
way around the dressing room when I
develop the pictures you could see like
just my stupid ads face in the
reflection of all the mirrors dude
holding this [ __ ] disposable camera
you know but that was like the first you
know time did that happen to me so yeah
I still remember that you know I suppose
disposable cameras and phone cards y'all
yeah dude yeah that was how he toured
back then you know until you stayed in
contact with those [ __ ] phone cards
used to kill me those [ __ ] ripped you
off
unless you went to a Kroger and they
give you minutes yeah those bodega ones
[ __ ] I do doesn't ask a birthday you
wanna have a [ __ ] scam yes thanks
yeah and they would say ten thousand
minutes or whatever you look if you get
a [ __ ] did every call for minutes
even if the person don't pick up dialing
to do it hits the answering machine you
have 36 minutes I just had 40 [ __ ]
minutes nobody talked to nobody you
marvellous [ __ ] dude I remember remember
remember back then like we played a show
in Cleveland and we ended up it was one
of those classic things where you end up
staying at a friend's house like right
after the show so I go hey I'm gonna
make a phone call I'm gonna call my my
girl at the time that whatever had a
phone card and he goes dude don't don't
walk like anywhere around here I was
like how bad get how bad it could be
Cleveland yes it's 1:00 in the morning
2:00 in the morning I'm just gonna make
a phone call I'm at I'm at this like
little tienda at the corner right and
I'm on I'm on a pay phone and sure
enough within like two minutes people
started throwing [ __ ] bottles driving
by throwing bottles at me while I'm on
the phone I was like I I better I better
go that's a bad idea
you have one minute our girls did know
the role the role is an interesting
place you learn I said like couple
months ago on the podcast once you put
yourself out into the universe as a
musician comedian a drummer and a band
once you put it out there you commit
fully the universe pays you little by
little it shows you signals to keep you
alive it may show you a bed for three
nights in somebody's basement you know
it's so weird that I had a friend that
owned the comic look after I played his
club a few times we became kind of
friends and he would tell me you want to
come up this week he and one of his
friends with a woman one of the friends
in the circle was a woman and when I
went to the house to eat and she's like
well surely it was like Tony Montana I'm
or the guy goes down so much at Columbia
the boss the act and the guy tells him
to leave
Pacino out of them she doesn't want to
leave your friend here well yeah he
could sleep downstairs you're on a warm
thought bus I have a landscaping
business and he could help me landscape
in the daytime and that night he could
do calmly locally and I was like Shawn
he's like that'd be great ideas on my
couch to pay any ass first three nights
it worked out great
the next morning one morning I wake up I
hit a deer open the door open up she
would get in bed open my legs
suck my pipe and then she'd go upstairs
make breakfast with kids like nothing
happened this went on every time I slept
there she wouldn't say a word about it
hey come downstairs take my dick out
second like a savage
I'd squirt she was going through a
divorce nobody knew nothing
wow I go upstairs eat breakfast mingle
with the kids
nice one of the kids hit me up about
four years ago on Facebook how you doing
[Laughter]
[ __ ] crazy yeah that really was crazy
yeah and we stayed friends I remember
being at her house with our audition for
The Sopranos the first time and her
helping me with the lines and we taking
a bus the next day to New York
wow she was a great lady just a great oh
if I was 38 35 she had to be 46 still
looking good nice huh
but it was wicked she'd come down the
door would creep open like I was
sleeping I cosby's out the blanket pick
up a hammer and I had already bangs when
I had that coming taste River Plus she
sucked that pipe dry again she wouldn't
say good morning she wouldn't even talk
just go right to it suck it yeah put it
back like where it was cool drink the
milk of debt I'm away up the Bears and
then cook breakfast for the kids hi
perfect and then some days I go away
right she never ever said nothing to me
did you pretend like you were asleep or
did he later like I was a molested child
jang seong foots along the massage join
this franco they give you a great
massage I take my wife there it's guys
and girls but the girl that works that
is kind of cute she's like a heavy
lifter the last night took her nap I
woke up my body heard something about a
fang Jun get the $40 special she sticks
her toes in my ass and then she moves
her knees yeah but she purposely sticks
her toes in my ass and I get down I'm on
one side of the jail though it's a big
deal you ever saying she feels me up she
pulled my underwear down in the back and
she - yes she pulled Miami on these down
halfway I said she rubs my back in my
ass cheek sometimes I
and she gets close to my [ __ ] yeah
that's probably a Chinese culture they
want to stick a finger up he has to
loosen you up
I wouldn't dive 9 1 1 oh I just hope my
smile wouldn't be there to him saying I
don't want to be walking around with
Cuban stink finger and then rub lovely
probably there once and then tell me
there's no way to bring shorts it's
tremendous before tea not you like Italy
it was good it was interesting doing it
next to him because I could hear him and
then that my guy was going kind of hard
on me but I know I couldn't say anything
because he would have tortured me and
then we like we fall asleep outside
getting the feet done because they do
the feet and I didn't think I was gonna
be into it especially because it was a
guy what I felt good did it and he did
anyone stick their toes and you're an
ass
no no I always get yeah baby Jesse I
always get I call first and it was Jesse
available [ __ ] should tell me exactly
when they get that come to 15 I stop
what I'm doing less you right over there
I go that way twice a month
I [ __ ] pepper heavy and she's
phenomenal Wow grips my shoulders apart
damn she rips my feet apart they have a
lunchtime special from 12 to 3 you gonna
give him the 20 you give that little
Chinese guy a 5 before the party even
starts yeah before he touches you give
them I finally put your feet in hot
water
they rub your shoulders they rub your
neck they do a bunch of stuff that's
what my hair was [ __ ] up last night
because having a massage to scout ah you
know how does they do your hands they
bit poor knuckles out ok and the
Trotters pretty 20 for 40 bucks or 20
right now it well [ __ ] right up the
corner right attendee from Bank of
America okay yeah heat somewhere in
there there's a luncheonette yeah
there's uh
a toenail plays a Korean note toenail
plays and there's that says massage it's
not a [ __ ] place yeah all the other
ones are like there's a Thai place
there's a Thai massage place when I
heard a real yeah but the chicks are
brutal they're really Brown yeah they
look weird
ain't nobody fed them in a year I wasn't
there one day and I might be too skinny
to give me a [ __ ] massage you weigh
85 pounds him they got it by the waist
no chain chain to the [ __ ] rim look I
like that sand joke I've been going over
there for two years
damn when I saw the happy hour 420 I was
like you know and then somebody told me
somebody referred me time five years ago
they said going there they're good they
would you just got hmm no I really liked
it
I have to check that out leech era death
they break your neck they do everything
over Ricky they do whatever you need you
know so [ __ ] up right now and yeah do
the special later on my Bacchus forty
minute special astronaut Jesse she's not
down on Wednesdays well on Wednesdays
your [ __ ] you got a bunch of guys don't
look like extras in a Bruce Lee movie
except that the cigarette he looks just
like the big boss in the big boss anyway
I mean how much do you guys do take care
of yourself cause like it can't be easy
going onstage 30 nights and like 30
nights it's like not much I try to do I
try and do as much cardio and I'm home
as I can we actually can yeah ever I can
but I mean on the road it's it's it's a
little tougher on the road but I stretch
a fuckload
before we even go on just to kind of
help me but I still came back home from
the last of all with a [ __ ] that back
the first time I've ever ever in my life
had a [ __ ] up back ever
it's okay sucks you know those long time
those long sitting I can't sit that long
though yeah
I used to be able to sit that long those
days are done that that Doug got shot
Jeff yeah I usually right now even less
sitting right yeah I gotta put a timer
on I'm gonna get up and [ __ ] do yeah
how is it less yeah oh you get too stuck
yeah I get a [ __ ] I have a
degenerative disc and it just it acts up
flares up from time to time I also can't
sit you know for very long because I
feel that pressure yeah getting right in
there so you look down to compute it
yeah that adds more pressure like an OP
typing into I don't know this somebody
read me the riot act so it's really
interesting that well I had no [ __ ]
and I didn't it's different
now is that one thing about you that I
really liked that every musician should
do
I mean Mick Jagger leaks but he's my
jacket but he weeks his rehearsal tapes
by himself like his dance yeah yeah and
him lifting weights and doing [ __ ]
cow bells at 73 and his trainers like
this 23 year old that's topless is [ __ ]
Mick Jagger don't [ __ ] around he's
whipping that [ __ ] I'm saying yeah big
jack he doesn't have no Bruce Lee extras
there's real people there but it's so
weird how what the [ __ ] was like how you
connected with social media you've taken
off ever since you did the podcast and I
started following you you are fantastic
at it
thanks man and not like in a shitty way
like chicks with tits and let's face it
that's it you want to see [ __ ] in the
rock star I don't want to see pictures
of kids or you would charge you with a
bunch of guys how I was sober not sober
October you have to give me the delusion
that you're living this life yeah why is
it I mean thanks to you guys man that's
when it I really kind of started you
know getting a little bit more in touch
with that
because after the first time I was on
was when I just started to get [ __ ]
people starting to hit me up like left
and right and I was like man I need to
like [ __ ] need to get on this thing
because it's a different [ __ ] age now
than before you know we we didn't grow
up with with that we didn't have that so
I've been sort of having to learn how to
[ __ ] use it you know and how to you
grew up with a picture of owl on your
wall yeah
today if I [ __ ] bug out enough on
Twitter eventually he'll crack and tell
me to go [ __ ] myself
yeah because first they start saying
hello to you like you're a nice person
if you take them for granted and then
you know what your assess [ __ ] you you
piece of [ __ ] you go [ __ ] you to
[ __ ] and that makes their world
yes that makes their world that they got
you pissed off and you block they
blocked you right you really got your
thumb you're a made guy at the bar got
blocked by gene simmons too late I told
them the way was it crazy it sounds like
a typical day at rehearsal
no but it really is that now the control
the fan has yeah and the control that
you have over that fan as a musician you
know Ozzy Osbourne couldn't wheat bran
him didn't tweet when those five junkies
from Boston took over the country in the
mid-70s didn't tweet they made that
bones in Worcester and all those [ __ ]
hell holes now all over Boston and they
became who they were could you imagine
you could tweet then Jesus videos well
you know you're half there was no I'm TV
and 75 right here II didn't come around
to 180 180 maybe Jim anyone I'm 91 a
member of 81 yeah video children in your
son what the [ __ ] now you know but last
night I had precious time on I had
precious time on I came over your last
night we smoked beer and we've merely
just to get the munch started off great
this lazy edge on cuz I was with the
family all day with the church choir
that I fell asleep I woke up but I want
to get massages the gin gin place we'd
meet me over at the [ __ ] office at
Hsu a [ __ ] grandma some bubblicious
together we go Lee asked me cause I
believe with you higher this morning
yeah where are you I go not really I
just went home and I had the peanut
butter and jelly sandwich a banana to
apples just taking bong hits with Joey's
crate like when I think I'm done like
there's no way I could take another bong
hit Weasley's that we had two more we
went right through grammar 25% week oh
wow me and him a gram straight back for
Danny we were playing checkers
we're playing what is that battle b-52
we play battleship bong hit last night
wow we just walk back at four and so we
couldn't see I drove in everybody was
sleeping I thought they were asleep and
then they woke up with belly aches and
[ __ ] I'm high as [ __ ] said did you did
you guys cut out the edibles yes yeah
well more no more at all too intense you
know what's the wow yeah yeah
it wasn't intense the way like I think
normal people think of intense because
we were taking like a minimum of 1,500
and that was a white light Oh for like
three years
you go home you wake up this composition
all ovation I still remember the [ __ ]
the Pauly Shore yeah and it was time to
evolve I wanted to get better
conversation other people sure it's
tough for me to give you a star and you
me and it's cute but you know what man
were adults sure so it was a different
direction I love when things evolve yeah
I don't want to see a show that stays
the same forever
I remember kids parent
one time when the last Led Zeppelin out
came up in through the out door whenever
we're at the house and the mother came
in and her husband was a jazz drummer so
she knew music and she does you know I'm
not crazy about what Zeppelin but one
thing about them is on all the realms
they have a different sound mmm like
they showed up with a different sound
one different thing you know yeah and I
believe it's the same whether it's
podcasting a TV show give me a different
dimension to let the upper all my mind I
thought it was just time plus the edible
business why not had a business here oh
you gotta eat 80 things for you to get
high ain't got time to fill my stomach
but found jello dust that [ __ ] jello
dust makes you [ __ ] and yeah high-tier
[ __ ] it out the next morning you wake up
until you take this [ __ ] yard you tell
me you take a [ __ ] you're like wow high
no more you should smell like the
edibles to the floors I've got a ball it
clogs everything up everything had jello
on it I had more jello in my system you
can't the cookies diabetes you can t
just giving you diabetes you're eating
cookies and brownies and so what you're
trying to strive for is the smallest
thing I could give you with the
strongest potency you know they had to
spray the spray was pretty good thousand
you know they're spraying like Bellanca
like y'all had breath next thing you
know you're hammered it was great
I just uh I'm just 55 oh yeah for
something no you don't try to do
anything what about the drinks we've
done the drinks don't like them
yeah don't like them I'm very old-school
when it comes to that I still flour the
process of cutting it you know what's
one thing this new narco show tells you
is how the Mexicans were slug on brown
marijuana into the country they can't
control of it but this guy came up with
a way and to eliminate the male sea from
the female sea to make it stronger so he
does show me a kilo of Europe wheat and
the guy took out like a suitcase and he
goes this is a kilo of our
we could smuggle more you know and I
still remember being a kid and
sinsemilla eating something that was its
answer me Abba dad knew Bob Marley
showed up with [ __ ] Wragge and five
black dudes with dreadlocks and he had a
we called lambsbread it's another
Jamaicans were so our part of the
country we had more Brown Mexican we'd
know we had more Colombian gold and
Panama red mmm and grandmas bread then
the West Coast the West Coast had the
Mexican Brown and the sensimilla and
then to make real money the sense of me
is started crossing over we started
seeing green weed mmm
instead of brownish reddish goldish weed
and that was just a complete different
but even when you got like the Columbian
gold and a lot of seeds in it if you
bought an eighth of it it was all seeds
that's why when you buy a whole vital
mm-hmm when you open it up a seed or
fall out because that's how you clean
your we the 70s right yeah why you
bought the album you took the album art
you put it out and then as you roll the
joint you rolled on the thing the seeds
would go to the middle of the album you
would scrape the weed and roll a joint
so that's what people use their albums
for to [ __ ] clean the weed out I'm
[ __ ] amazing Wow nice Wow what Ames
what about what do you guys know about
CBD oil I love it
yeah I love it i buy this one brand and
what I do is listen I know this right
knee is gone so after your shows before
you shows before you put the knee pads
on you know you you go to right now when
we leave here get in your car and get on
to hung down and just go straight and go
straight to Ventura and make a left on
rent or there's a place called urban
trees and you go and then it comes in a
bottle and you even just like cans or
Sun lotion it has pain reliever and you
I put it on my knees some
if I'm squatting I put it on my legs on
my arms plus I've been doing shoulder
therapy on my own so I pushed my hands
to rub it into my shoulders every
morning look that's what I have
Wow um I jerked my shoulders a long
years so I do use a lot of CBD the cream
yeah and I rubbed it into my wife's back
last night she didn't complain but its
pain reliever and you feel it you feel
it you're helping they have a roll-on
too cuz I need something from my back
man yes buddy to me rub and they even
have CBD oil that you rub on your clip
that's a woman's [ __ ] just go [ __ ]
bananas just [ __ ] tequila sunrises in
your face insane did we use that Lee no
I mean use that one my I do have a buddy
who has cerebral palsy and he says he he
can't live without it is he doing the
oil he has a roll drum - he's a roll-on
for like it was joints ever heard I
think the one probably worked good for
me I do the drops in the vape and they
the vape actually helps throughout the
day you know I mean of the the oil I
usually do it at night and you know I
get good good night's rest and back
doesn't hurt as much it still hurts I
mean the paint's still there but I mean
it's just because I haven't I'm curious
here I wrecked or anything never tried
when I go home I start to CBD without
the THC yeah
which isn't as efficient it should have
a little bit of THC to drive it to
yourselves or another place that should
get that I don't know what this is
exactly a terminology people don't
listen to me
but I do it and I feel a lot better than
the more I thought I said yesterday now
I went to jujitsu Friday and Saturday
back-to-back and I worked out at home
Thursday and I thought I [ __ ] yesterday
and I got worse throughout the body
aches and [ __ ] yeah just you saw you're
55 years old there's not really much
testosterone you saw now is it hum is it
the one that has some THC in it is it
are
different levels of how much yeah there
is yes you can get the one with the
least yeah just to make the body aches
you're on stage you're really playing
yeah take the CBD or rub it on your
fingers or your guitar yeah I feel like
it's single my joints yeah is where I
start to feel it yeah and then my
[ __ ] lower back yeah absolutely
you're on state doing your thing shaking
yet every time yeah shake it that's
three seconds off your life yeah yeah
I'm your [ __ ] head you might as well
have Lee tackle you 22 times anything
happens to you head you wake up in the
morning it's like what the [ __ ] happened
anyways that was the Disneyland I say
dungeon in 44 hours mostly [ __ ] yeah I
gotta try that that's way [ __ ] better
and then eatin pills and yeah yeah yeah
you're organized right that what's the
name of that place you said right now
that's called urban trees stay open to
hunger and Ventura to hung in Ventura
they're open from 8 to 10 and while
you're there you might as well vote down
the corner you really want to rock your
world
from one brother to another yeah you you
park right there and then you get out
and you walk 30 yards to a place called
us cryotherapy hmm and dump to freeze
your hands Wow for three minutes
yeah and loosen it up damn and if it
works for you then come back again
before the tour starts nice and going
the chamber for three minutes
[ __ ] so cryo chamber cryo chain up with
your head for three minutes [ __ ]
awesome because right now you guys are
gonna be doing some heavy plans so you
want your body to recover yeah it's
tough and thank God knock on wood you
don't drink alcohol now thank God you
take care of yourself cuz our balls the
one that really gets you on the road
yeah that's what really gets you got
pills you around for nights it's not the
road it's not you doing what you love
it's the after yeah mmm mmm the four
hours of sleep the drinking no breakfast
yeah man I couldn't I couldn't [ __ ] I
mean you know because I've
we drink I've never done anything I
can't imagine what it's like you know
and I see it I mean everyone around us
you know [ __ ] does [ __ ] and I'm just
like man that's gotta be I'm feeling
just because of my age you know you just
you don't feel like you did in your 20s
anymore
so now add that [ __ ] on top of it I
can't [ __ ] imagine there's a headache
you know I definitely can't get into the
bus like you know like feet like if I
smell somebody's feet the windows are
closed [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] get sick if I'm hungover
yeah do the tour bus there's no you know
open windows yeah people [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
a bus bathroom we're in the bunk and the
bunk on the bunk I'm late you had talked
dirty to get me on the bus I did when I
was in prison I had a bus ride with
handcuffs on yeah everything Harvey
suits the slippers you couldn't talk I
like all that [ __ ] fun little ride but
after 30 I don't want to be on the bus
with stinky man is she like this way as
this tour start I'm Francisco Wednesday
this Wednesday is 21st San Francisco at
the Warfield and it goes till when till
December 21st what's the website uh
ministry ministry BAM calm yeah you
[ __ ] ready to rock
[ __ ] yeah I'm ready best to hell I will
keep I gotta get him on here one of
these days man you come back with the
whole [ __ ] trial for sure for sure
sure would hit will blow up absolutely
yeah what uh how long just told go to
one month November 21st to December 21st
and then when LA hopefully you guys can
come out what were they Fonda December
20th and December 21st and that's fond
of isn't it that's on Hollywood
Boulevard
it's it's close to the Palladium okay
it's right it's right like a few blocks
from the Palladium it's a nice place
very nice place that's like nice white
people yeah that'll need that now
they're gonna do I don't know what the
[ __ ] you know man they don't need that
no one was bathrooms without a MIDI
ability yes
the Japanese backlight and put it in
their spray every god
oh that's chlamydia STB what's that site
that you get you swipe dinner tender
vision tender tender this as from
getting [ __ ] on tinder bill call it
yeah come down for those shows man
awesome I love to come down I'm I get
her back to New York on the 19th okay
cool man
I'll come down to one of the show yeah
hello see what fastened on great that'd
be great now see my boy [ __ ] do his
thing look at me looks like a young Jim
sigh ow I want people to go on YouTube
that can't I ow he went on [ __ ]
steroids it's that that cam work in
fields so the lasted real quick the last
US tour that we did which was the
beginning of the year we were in Canada
I forget where we were it might have
been I think it was it might have been
Toronto it might have been Vancouver I'm
not too sure but we were at this bar
next door right hanging with some people
and this you know it's not some girl -
and her husband tell me you know you
remind me of you remind me of a Kim fail
from Soundgarden and I go that's funny
oh that's that's my dad
that's my dad and she was like shut up
[ __ ] no I find it I go that's my dad and
I had her convinced that you know Al and
and my dad Kim were were like friends
from back in the wallet Palooza days and
and I got in the band and I I I didn't
have that opportunity that something
happened in between and I didn't have
that time to tell her that I was joking
and they [ __ ] bought it and they
thought that I would that that was that
my dad the entire [ __ ] night one
night things confound 100 min II Apple
as his ad died no some [ __ ] couple
comes up come and said we met your son
at a [ __ ] bar and whatever
I can finally bothering nobody [ __ ]
airport lenses old dude sitting coach
you don't want nobody no it's some
people gonna call go go we may I got no
son my son's got missing an ear
he's running Miller yeah I want to thank
both you guys for coming out all of you
manage it thank you keep doing what
you're doing don't forget on it Black
Friday sale it's that time of the year
[ __ ]
it starts Thanksgiving November 22nd the
biggest [ __ ] sale of the year nothing
is off-limits including the number one
nootropic alpha brain all Marvel and
Star Wars fitness equipment for you
[ __ ] Momo's that want to swing
Superman and [ __ ] like that go get a
girlfriend go son get your dick sucked
but anyway we even got total humans on
sale and to top it all forever out of
the stripper off the free shipping the
qualifying purchases so 25% on
supplements
18% on Fitness and that's including the
Star Wars and Marvel and certification
20% to our foods
50% of DVDs and 30% off apparel in
addition you're gonna get a $10 coupon
maybe some free shipping premium free
gifts are also available at this time
Lee listen you want to make 2019 the
best year of your life by stocking up
now whether it's shroom tech alpha brain
whatever I'm telling you right now so
mark it down
Thanksgiving 9 o'clock we're going to
launch an amazing doorbuster deals go to
islet calm Black Friday
if you light something don't forget
about You uncle Joey slash in church
don't just sit there like [ __ ] anyway
on it calm Black Friday slash Church
through your thinking [ __ ]
don't forget also it's Thanksgiving Day
Eli said they were your [ __ ] feet
family watching football like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't want to bet
the game you got a bet the game what the
[ __ ] bet a little bit you want to place
a bet be afraid I got the wrong theme
that's really he's always got the wrong
team you still see him putting them bets
this Thanksgiving it's finally possible
can't give up for you to get 100% refund
on your bet if you lose it with the
turkey day free play you can bet the
spread on either the bears or the Lions
and if it wins guess what you win if it
loses my book will give you your money
back up to $250 you literally cannot
lose it there's only we can lose at this
no it's no risk all gravy some probably
let's this game the stadium will fall
down Isis will strike something will
happen is the kiss of death no I can't
get it no please
my bookie life was such a great product
that they literally never been a better
time to try them out unless your sports
book is offering something like this and
they're not I write salt listen let's
get it together
these guys are trustworthy fast and
helpful and I know that good to you you
play you win and you get paid and that's
the most important thing if you're new
to sports betting you got questions
that's okay because my bookies got a
patient customer service can walk you
through any questions you have about how
betting works sign up this week today
right now my book you'll give you 50%
off deposit bonus just to start your
bankroll it's a great way in a bank
either more money when you win so log in
to my bookie right now use promo code
Church they get 50% off deposit bonus
that's promo code Church to get 50%
deposit bonus you don't need a promo
code for turkey day pre-play that's on
you alright if you lose will credit the
money back in your account automatically
now what the hell are you waiting for
sign up today and don't miss out the
gravy trains on my bookie I want to
thank my man since I want to thank my
man Caesar Caesar aka MC Allen he I want
to thank my man the Jew killer [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't matter like juice
Juke
[ __ ] what's the difference and
I want to thank you guys for being
family I want you to have a happy
Thanksgiving we'll do another podcast
this week don't forget my booking on it
both shows this week a sold-out
Wednesday sold out in her vine and
Friday night sold I never I want to
thank you for the love always and the
support any way you put it you hear from
us Wednesday morning tip-top but who
ready to go all right kick this [ __ ]
mule you have a great day
stay black we'll start your Monday on
the right foot